[Musique]
mais petite beauté on va se retrouver
dans un instant avec karine le marchand
qui sera notre invité est oui pour un
amour être le frais et on aura tibs qui
sera avec nous on adore ce chanteur il
va nous faire le jeu de l'actuelle
aujourd'hui ça va être la folie pour le
moment je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous regardent et beaucoup de gens
qui ont passé le bac aujourd'hui pour la
plupart des gens c'était le bac
scientifique tu pouvais tu peux y aller
tu peux y aller tu payes à l'émotion
c'est le bac scientifique aujourd'hui
pour la plupart et bac scientifique qui
dit blake scientifique dit bien sûr
expérience et regardez nous sommes au
soleil
nous sommes bien nous sommes avec tout
le monde avec toute l'équipe qui est là
les cherry et ils vont vous faire chacun
une expérience une expérience une
expérience de chimie ya benjamin
castaldi bien sûr qui a préparé son
expérience et vous chez vous vous allez
parier sur celui qui fera la meilleure
expérience on a une auditrice en ligne
une téléspectatrice
c'est parti mais pour l'instant on a
déjà l'expert scientifique parce qu'il
ya deux personnes expertes entité qu'au
téléphone
bonsoir aliette comment ça va ça va et
toi ma chérie tu en as plus très bien je
suis très content de t'avoir alors à la
turbie tout s'est très vite au 19ème à
paris adacore très bien alors tuer tuer
tuer
vraiment tu es quoi tu espères
scientifique ah oui c'est très très fan
de chimie et puis j'ai une très bonne
très bonne note au bac
d'accord mais tu à dire que je l'aimé
curé quoi dans la vie j'étais ingénieur
avait qualité dans une entreprise pour
l'aéronautique d'accord très bien ma
chérie et va très bien c'est important
chacun tout le monde à vous faire une
expérience ici les cherry on est au
soleil
on est bien sachez que c'est la dernière
semaine pour moi et oui après je mettrai
fin à cette saison voilà ce sera
vendredi 23 au frein énorme prime avec
toute l'équipe et il y aura même les
quatre tiers de jean-luc lowinsky ya
beaucoup de gens qui me disent pourquoi
les quatre tiers ne sont pas là depuis
deux trois semaines et bien jean-luc va
vous répondre parce que je vais faire
des chrétiens xxxl voila voila mon jour
libye syrie on a d'abord une expérience
de bazar à castaldi est ce que c'est
dangereux c'est wyeth qui va nous dire
celui qui a fait la meilleure expérience
d'accord at-on la victime a fait la
meilleure expérience pour toi tu irais
géraldine parce que les trop d'accord
bonjour et dit j'aurais des jean-luc
mais bon on va voir en tout cas on sait
déjà qu'il va faire la plus mauvaise
expérience je pense avoir une petite
idée
cap au sud merci alors ben jama vous
allez avoir une expérience alors
regardez chez vous vous pouvez la faire
mais pas chic mais attention faites
attention d'accord c'est vous allez
prendre toutes les précautions pas
dangereux
alors c'est quoi alors c'est un mélange
d'eau et de maïtena baïse et là on va
rappeler ce que c'est c'était peu de
farine
donc je vais rien c'est de l'amidon de
maïs analyse voilà donc la shna ces jeux
là là c'est fluide voyez en revanche si
je suis en mouvement ses impressions que
c'est une cata sa part été tuées en
mourir et la cdu auriez là c'est dur
qu'ils arrêtent up est alors grandeur
nature imaginées
j'ai rempli se battre là ouais
l'appareil c'est fluide et a laissé
comme de l'eau ouais ces jours ci je
mets les pieds dedans mais moi je
m'enfonce pas ah oui vous avez pas vous
enfoncez beaucoup de regarder à huy ah
oui c'est vrai ou faux pas a dit en fait
lors être les amis de chez moi non
newtonien donc ça c'est hélas oui il ya
des scènes un arrêt allait saigner volé
à ray charles et stéphane on sait où
vous pas balle à auby s'enfonce pas bah
quand même un peu moins les plus longs
mais le poids ouais je vois passer ça
oui c'est fort alors pour ça fait ça y
est c par rapport à la nudité et la
mondialisation des deux en gros quand on
est là maintenant avec le bras doucement
fait ça devient une cible et quand on
les force intrigue est née d'un coup tu
as devient que l'ip et du côté pas
homogène d'accord bon c'est un peu une
expérience de merde mais ça lui donnera
non non alors moi je vous fabriquer du
gaz carbonique et je vais parler sous
contrôle du professeur castaldi k1
connaît très très bien cette expérience
il n'a pas arrêté de m'en parler
il n'a même pas nettoyé pas pu ouvrir le
truc dont il valait genou va mal on m'a
souvent au dernier moment à l'heure
actuelle
voilà je fais ce que je peux un accord
alors on va lui laisser ouvert ses bras
la série noire deviendra dans la semaine
non mais regardez regardez
voilà là alors professeur castaldi
regarder alors je prends ça alors il
faut pas le manipuler avec les banques
ça c'est quoi ça alors ça c'est la glace
blatter monique alors il faut pas la
manipuler avec les mains surtout pas je
vais la mettre là dedans
ouais mais là il faut de l'eau en
revanche elle est la nôtre elle est là
merci merci
et attention regardez ici va se passer
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est
que ça va créer du gaz carbonique qui
sera plus léger que l'air c'est bien ça
un plus lourd plus lourd pardon donc là
vers mont royal ier qu'est ce qui va se
passer l'ariana dans la foule fumée
lourdes normalement normalement si tout
va bien christophe tu devrais avoir de
la fumée voilà tu vois c'est pour ça
qu'il nous fait chier depuis tout à
l'heure
attendez-vous à droite kaka qui fume on
va voir la fumée dense et très bien
passionnant que c'était vous regarde et
vois la série pour annoncer match
combien j'avais déjà la meilleure
concert bah oui parce que là vous avez
besoin pour votre expérience
bon elle a pour l'instant je mets 5 5
sur 5 sur 10
et là je mets 3 sur 10 ha ouais je vais
vous montrer que quand on remplit un sac
de congélation en plastique qu on le
remplit d'eau on peut les transpercer
avec des crayons sans que l'eau
s'échappe du web un bail ou merde qu'on
trouve les noms oui c'est possible que
je le rate j'ai pas fait cours chimie
moi jamais allez-y alors bon alors là on
mélo déjà la hausse a déjà c'est facile
ouais mais vous m'avez [ __ ] tout clos
un break où tu es sûrement rien à st
louis avec talgo la menace des ménages
j'ai passé ma vie j elle aimait callas
einstein nasa décoller la voiture c'est
un truc de ouf ça va les laisser à la
rame est bien fermée machin n'a pas
souhaité le faire
voila.fr mais cherche aussi je serai pas
toujours là au bac tu seras toute seule
ma peine bon bah tu seras tout seul tu
seras dans la mer dans une merde noire
même si vous pouvez me le tenir après
c'est les petits pets tout va mal finir
vasily félin foot voilà voyez si je fais
ça non mais ça y est ça crève pas
pourquoi la rater oui il est constitué
de plastique ou autrement dit des faux
les mérites et enterrant taxer une perte
de fortes et comme un jouet elle a passé
al saqqa la passe et rayssac volant elle
sur sa alors elle jeu mais un jeu mais
un voit la participation alors on y va
alors une balle de ping pong
ouais c'est très inflammable at en effet
garde quand même pas qu'on allait cette
fois là pour voir ce que l'ue veut je l'
enveloppe légèrement repris là où elle
avait ouvrait la grille ouvrez tous là
je le sens pas du tout là c'est un peu
dangereux mais normal on se met à faire
ce que tu me laisses une cheminée ne le
fait pas c'est vous non pas du tout je
laisse une cheminée je laisse une
cheminée pour la balle de riz qui va
créer quoi je crée le feu poussez-vous
isabelle ça s'appelle le fumigène maison
avait fait gaffe à ton ses intentions
attention écartée je ne suis pas le
fumigène
normalement la salle à ça commence à
brûler bon moi je me bats il va tout
péter ce qu'ont d'ailleurs un problème
c'est que ça brûle pas
mourir et les deux là c'est un fiasco
alors allez être qu est ce qu ils
pensent que brûler le pousse énormément
ouais là la balle et on a mis à l'essai
la merde prison soit bac littéraire
c'est pour çà a laissé bon allez gilles
c'est vrai et c'est au liban merci on à
jean-luc gens là vous je vais 0 j'ai
bien ri 000 j'ai une bouteille en verre
j'ai de l'eau à l'intérieur c'est de
l'eau normale
je prends une balle de ping-pong jeux
rebouge sa bouteille
oui ayano elles sont pas bâlois elle
tombe pas vrai at on est regardé chez
vous chez vous qui fait de la france a
un incroyable talent
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu tout
ça c'est fort comme il l'a fait parce
que la balle elle serait vraiment j'ai
passé vente élevé de l'air et l'oxygène
comme ça on l'a rendu prisonnier et ça
fait à créer ce phénomène d'aspiration
un appel d'air du coup ça voilà un
retour via le docteur à 9 kilos d'écart
sont alors vous allez on vous voit pas
là on sait même pas qui vous êtes
enlever votre chapeau à ok merci
messieurs alors j'ai un magnifique
cercle oui formé par des bonbons à
montrer les merlus ont coloré entraîneur
la caméra à l'épaule et assiettes
creuses en vrai et je vais verser à
l'intérieur mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer expliqué nous qui va y avoir une
sorte de dessins de mosaïque de couleurs
multicolores sur cette assiette
c'est ça la ccx mazet dévoile les
coulisses à m renard mais ça m a fait
rire je vais mettre de l'eau un petit
peu chaude c'est d'havré aux à ces deux
lots show doit donc là on a besoin de
quoi pour les téléspectateurs une
bouilloire et l'eau est à 80 degrés elle
est très très chaud donc attention à
chez vous et vous mettez juste décoincer
les crs de la mrc des skittles faut le
dire va céder ses preuves et ouvert ce
s'interdire pas s'il faut le dire si on
arrête pas comment je voulais vous
demander l'assiette c'est le résultat
est très jolie j'étais très jolie en
principe oui on se régale alors monsieur
magnifique en fait ça font quoi oui la
merde en boite non non c'est une autre
au work in progress à voler leur secret
ça m'est donné c'est très malin et
s'étend même à donner à fond à temps les
bonnes et wars et pearl away ça c'est la
cfld période mais regardez ça mais j'ai
dit ouais franchement c'est moi elle a
créé des régions d'études pour nous
faire ça ça y est c'est bon ça assez
poétique c'est joli c'est bien parce que
c'est toi car bien sûr géraldine
géraldine jeu mais je mets cet aphorisme
un manager à vous alors moi je ne
voulais plus être un ton magique une
expérience au cas je vais vous montrer
que en enlevant le
le billet la pièce de deux euros elle va
rester sur la bouteille normalement
c'est pas possible il rend la monnaie
aussi regarder en milieu de mois
essayait déjà essayé déjà jean luc mais
non mais faut il mouille et le droit et
en fait d'un coup hop à bas prix - 2 et
- dans le plus grand cabaret du monde
jean-michel cesser leur lobby niveau
qu'on est là c'était sabah à soda d'une
marque on ne citera pas plus d des
mentos voilà les montrent au scrution à
très lisse et en fait il ya plein de
petites aspérités laxiste qu'on appelle
des espaces on se rend physique des
espaces de nucléation est élu il
explique bien j'aime bien en plongeant
les menteuses dans l'eau gazeuse synchro
aucune réaction en chaîne des bulles
d'oxygène et boissons la remontée à la
surface et provoquait en passer qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent alors j'espère que sa
véritable explosion voici je dois pas me
paraît presque mélangeant laissez le
faire
c'est un professionnel ouais ça va péter
n'est pas c'est beau jeu mais n'offrent
pas si c'est parce qu'il a très bien
expliqué exclu bravo mesdames oui alors
que je prends cette bouteille d'eau
alors qu'elle aurait donc bien alors je
vous ai g et vous n'expliquez pas vous
expliquer avec cette bouteille d'eau et
se poivre je vais vous montrer
l'attention des molécules à la surface
de l'eau je sais même pas ce qu'elle
dira d'où viennent-elles commères
rockets alors à la surface de l'eau les
molécules d'eau forme une membrane du
tout tendues donnez-moi l'antisèche sur
la table sur des coûts qui en suit donc
je mets un peu d'eau ici dans ce dans
cette assiette
je crois beaucoup de poids vous allez
voir que le poivre serait parti de façon
uniforme sur l'ensemble du truc vraiment
hausse sauf que on m'écoutait ou pas
vous en avez rien à [ __ ]
sauf que dans des genres mais encore un
petit peu
elle est sans rivale et je me suis
endormi moi je vais mettre du liquide
maîtresse de coton tige maudit oui on
lui remet dans ça vous allez voir que le
liquide vaisselle va faire que le poivre
se dispersent sur les bords de
l'assiette c'est génial j'ai connu on va
terminer on va terminer sur cette
extravagance bien voir bien avoir deux
présidents après ouais tu connais le
huawei a franchement pas mal c'est bien
mais j'adore ce truc là je me fait mal
cet ennemi je mets cet ennemi lauder
alors ça c'est pas dangereux les enfants
peuvent nous faire voilà vous pouvez
faire les membres et mentaux attention
ça sent peut le refaire les bonbons
c'est très sympa ça met tout de suite
l'ambiance inclus en milieu campagnard
en milieu agricole et l'urbain ça fait
toujours son succès ça ça oui mais ça
c'est ripoux alors ils peuvent voilà ça
ne le fait pas voilà je vous le dis je
vais vous dire le grand gagnant
pour moi c'est jean michel mr ouai café
une expérience connu mais qui l'a très
bien expliqué bravo jean miché merde et
la meilleure expérience celui qui a été
le plus fort c'est jean luc lemoine et
de rien parce que il a fait une prouesse
technique
j'avais parié sur jean luc lemoine donc
je considère que les gens lui que moi de
gagner donc à y est puisque j'avais
parié sur jean-luc 6 et je te fait
gagner ton smartphone c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mathieu
merci à yad abord est avec nous à chéri
mais merci à vous tous continuer tout ce
que vous faites on vous aime on nous
rassure vous encore les chéris nous
reste plus que cinq émissions va se
retrouver tout de suite en plateau avec
toute l'équipe à l'ats carine marson
avec type on a des infos médias on va
jouer ou là des scoops
on a une équipe de fous c'est les 5
dernières ça m